non sans charisme
[Musique]
j'espère que vous êtes prêts parce
qu'ils vont pas tarder c'est un fusil
l'a jamais vu de fusée parce qu'avant
c'était plutôt moins les flingues et toi
les et plus mais bon apparemment tu t'es
aussi mise au flop j'étais pas au
courant c'est chaud
je vois tout ça la peur
la jalousie
a trahi son
de vous
débarrassé l'univers
roll on m'avait dit que vous étiez des
crétins prétentieux je sais pas du tout
brackett quoi j'avais un truc dans la
nuit oh mais tu as un chef
[Applaudissements]
encore sauver la galaxie
oui
seignal on va pouvoir augmenter nos
tarifs
si on devient sauveteurs de galaxies à
plein temps
[Musique]
sa fraîcheur
parfois tu t'aperçois que la chose que
tu as passé ta vie à chercher
et là depuis toujours à côté de toi par
exemple
vous savez faire c'est voudriez dessus
vous êtes pas d
non on est une famille
mais je suis pas sûr
[Musique]
ça fait des années que je te cherche et
vous êtes qui vous je suis ton père
peter